we spoke about Andrew huberman today
what's your thoughts on him his
contributions
um overarchingly is one of the best
educational resources I would say that
is
um also one of the only individuals that
I believe to be very very
uh I don't know like dedicated to
putting out the best information even at
the detriment of potential views like he
will not just host people who will get
high views he will host people that he
feels are have high level contribution
to the community at large and are
educational and could otherwise inform
him of things he doesn't even know and
he's very open to criticism even from
YouTubers who aren't medically qualified
like myself like he did not get upset or
annoyed when I first uh reacted to one
of his uh Joe Rogan episodes and I had
talked about
um some of the stuff he said about uh
some of the bodybuilding drugs he had
mentioned some of the interactions with
endocrine hormones I kind of did one of
my classic reaction videos and gave kind
of my insight on what I felt to be
correct and he was very very polite in
like a lot of people could take that the
wrong way and be like I'm a [ __ ] like
world top tier neuroscientist and you
piece of [ __ ] YouTuber you don't know
anything who are you to talk about this
and he was not like that at all he you
know we've become decent friends I would
say since then he's uh I'm always open
to learning even if it's from people who
aren't like medically credentialed which
is awesome because there are a lot of
people out there who are some of the
people I learned the most from aren't
MDS or guys who are otherwise seen as
you know the Forefront
on paper qualified person there are
people who are just entrenched in
learning more and are otherwise very
much doing the same thing he does too
where they'll just host people and learn
or dig into literature themselves stay
up to date on most of the on the most
Cutting Edge developments in
endocrinology pharmacology whatever it
is and he's uh yeah he's great it seems
like a rarity to have someone that has
got the scientific rigor and the
preparedness to go through what I
imagine aren't exactly entertaining
papers not exactly like a riveting read
yeah um to then take all of that out
look at what does this mean for the
everyday person and then turn it into
something that's an applied solution
like that's an awful lot of work and you
know the podcast is unbelievably
successful and he has this fantastic uh
platform now and uh his live shows are
going well and all the rest of it but
like
let's be fair he works as part as
podcasters go that man Works incredibly
hard for what he gets out it's not like
he's publishing an episode every single
day yeah he's not live streaming all the
time he's taking weeks months sometimes
to do research for a single episode this
one's going to be about grief this one's
going to be about a mating psychology
this one's going to be about exercise
science or whatever like this guy's gone
as deep as is possible on pretty much
anything and everything that's available
to do it the interesting thing a massive
fan of Andrew
become really like tight with him since
he came on the show and I find him like
a really giving like kind person which
again for that industry you'd think like
super artisty uh just a head in the
books without any compassion or whatever
and not the case either
the biggest difference or the
interesting thing that I realized I
think
since huberman's been on the scene
the biohacking community overall has
begun to look more and more silly to me
personally
um I don't know whether that's the case
for everybody else but the very sort of
experimental forward-thinking like super
out there stuff that was being done
kind of seems a a bit silly and under
evidenced give me an example uh red
light stunning on your balls and like
claiming that that's like the biggest
thing the most important thing that you
need to do
um PCP injections into like whatever
whatever [ __ ] part of your body in
order to be able to facilitate blah blah
blah like the um
different types of lights that people
would get either on glasses or around
their neck to activate certain glands or
whatever that I saw that was like a
thing for a big while these sort of um
necklaces almost that had lights built
into them that people would use like all
manner of wild [ __ ] that was happening
uh using uh like brain train EMF
machines in order to be able to optimize
your meditation practice and stuff like
that
in comparison with someone like huberman
who just comes out and goes this is what
the sign says this is what we know like
hard and fast this is something that has
evidence that backs it up this is a tool
that we can
fairly derive from those conclusions
this is something that you should try
with an appropriate amount of caveats
and to me
it's thrown the biohacking community in
a quite harsh light some of the elements
of the biohacking community that were
super out there now that being said
there are a bunch a bunch of things that
I'm sure that Andrew suggests that the
biohacking community was light years
ahead on but if you throw a lot of [ __ ]
at the wall inevitably some of it's
going to stick and I think in for a um
like bang for your buck yeah per minute
content consumption versus usable
strategy I think that the signs are out
that Andrew goes down is just like
Second To None yeah and he's very quick
to correct himself he only says
something that's wrong like I saw your
podcast with him and he even like went
and commented I made a mistake at this
part like how many people do that yeah
it was his uh
preparedness to not be
psychologically attached to the stuff
that he puts out there is something that
I think we all probably could learn a
little bit from because it's very
difficult and this is where I know that
you know to bring
Brian back into it
it must be difficult to have
your entire public Persona get dragged
now whether it was a contrived Persona
in an attempt to sell products that were
built off the back of a body that was
created using
that is by the by however
it's not easy it's not easy to be
criticized online like it [ __ ] sucks
like the difference between me and my
work
and how people perceive that and my
worth as a person and whether or not I
am fundamentally a piece of [ __ ] is like
kind of hard you know what I mean yeah
do you feel this I mean you know you're
regularly stepping into all manner of
different contested topics is this
something that you feel as well
um yeah like it's uh what is what is the
overarching question that you're trying
to ask here like how do I feel about
Twitter says I'm online okay I'm
personally involved with them yeah I
definitely read it and I probably should
be better about maybe not taking it so
personally when people are going to
disagree with you and sometimes you
could actually be wrong and
um you know I very much do acknowledge
when I'm incorrect on something and try
to be open to learning more and
um I don't know like I guess not being
so
dedicated to your way of wait your way
the highway is the only way is very
important to maintain I don't know
flexibility as a Creator and have the be
able to retain an audience long term and
have trust factor with them in that
you're not just dedicated to something
even at the detriment of it being wrong
or at their harm or something that you
then find out to be totally incorrect
like you know there's a lot of stuff
that
um back in the day I thought to be true
that ended up not being true and I
learned otherwise and you have to be
open to going back on that or else you
are not a high quality resource I would
say you have to be very open to the
criticism and or learning more in
general for sure what's happening people
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]